we are but 39 days I believe from the
electronic triple 2016 III is
approaching let's have that chat about
it let's do an update I can't feel like
we should just every week until until
you three starts with a couple of news
things happen this past week bunch of
things will happen over the past couple
of months actually is that a Nintendo
sort of slowly crept there to be three
couple years going on to the press
conference anymore did there in Nintendo
their event and then there you know the
direction and the tree has stuff which
was seemed seem to be very successful I
guess EA have decided to what I
completely Activision have decided to do
their own thing is what I was kind of
like doing their own off-site thing I'm
like devolver I guess the fall was the
first person to do that and Disney as
well won't be there I already sick
trailer park appears two years running I
think yeah yeah it's real good you go
play haha my hair stream river rad and
and then we just had news this week that
Nintendo are only going to be showing
one game which is basically Zelda rifle
yeah must be the we've seen what else
you need to show yeah so there would be
no new picross game i guess at e3 this
year at what do you guys think about
this we've you know III Zeb's and float
it sort of got back to its roots in the
past couple of years there was I year at
Santa Monica with a downsized and
basically everyone thought that was
awful and ended up going back to the
Moscone again what do you think about an
e3 without really much of a Nintendo
presence at all an en activation which
basically takes up most of the cell
phone I think it's kind of a little bit
down on a micro do you think it'll be
all right i paid down on it i think a
lot of us were pretty sure they were
gonna do something with the NX NY yep
and now it's delayed till 2017 yes very
least they said and i'm a huge zelda fan
and that's the one thing that they're
doing that I'm really looking forward to
well it's one of the things are doing
that I'm really looking forward to but I
don't know unfortunately I feel like in
the past four or five years Nintendo has
been taking a backseat as it is to like
everybody I mean Bethesda came out last
year with their first press conference
and you know fallout 4 jodas one of the
cool things we saw business press
conference last year was probably the
best pesco yeah the weekend and they
came out of nowhere I think they were I
haven't been that excited about Nintendo
at e3 in a long time
I'm not crazy surprised by this the more
it sinks in the more I'm just kind of
feel like it it's all the peace it makes
sense what about yourself I think you
have to separate as a game journalist
III the location with III the what we
learn rice III the location has ebbed
and flowed over the years but to be
honest the show floor is probably the
worst place to experience a game for a
gamer like as a gamer you want to be in
a quiet living room with your surround
sound system and a controller and just
be engaged right it's a fair point like
I to dream my entire life that like I
would love to go to e3 some year right
and the reality is that like it's great
to go and I every year it's like an
absolute privilege to walk into that at
all but soft like pax is so much better
for actually playing games aqui 3 is all
business and massive massive lines and
you don't really get access to a lot of
stuff so as a you know when you go there
as a journalist you would actually
rather be in a hotel a quiet hotel room
and be able to like experience the game
as the developer intended it because
nobody designs their game with like a
thousand people bumping into you and
screaming and like lights flashing it's
really a hard way to engage with with
video games so the content that's going
to happen at e3 this year I'm excited
about like we're going to get a lot of
shooter sequels we're not maybe like you
know somewhere in the LA area have a
playable version of battlefield hear
about titanfall 2 dishonored potentially
dishonored sequel I want to know where
Mass Effect Andromeda is that right I
mean there's a lot of stuff that we can
learn and if I'm sitting at a computer
and watching a live stream or in a hotel
room I don't care how I get that
information that really that's what
makes me excited as a gamer and most let
mean let's be honest it's not open to
the public so most people don't walk
around the show floor yeah it really
care about what happens on the show
floor yeah like no matter what the
information is gonna crash in its own
way I'm perhaps in a better way because
for the longest time that Microsoft and
Sony conferences would sort of cry me
and everyone else into there and nobody
had their own space to talk about it
whereas now we'll hopefully have it like
sort of petered out across the whole
week yeah you're right like ya are going
to show off all their stuff like they
always do and Fez are going to do their
own thing as well so it's interesting a
couple of people in the chart and
talking about how
you know comic-con same thing kinda
happening companies are avoiding these
big things or at least doing their own
thing at diallo's X saying I mean even
Square Enix out there thankful Final
Fantasy II know and for everything else
so a bit of a bit of a sea change what
are you looking forward to mostly
actually my cuz errands kind of talked
about a bunch of things he's looking for
it I'm excited to see what Nintendo will
show of Zelda assuming it is Zelda but
I'm also excited to see more of a
dishonor to I really like designer and
game former had their cover story yeah
today and I haven't got the chance to
look at it I'm really excited to read
through that because i really like
dishonor the first I know you've been
playing recently to Aaron and I I really
invention to see what they do with Emily
because she's a cool character the first
game now that she's kind of you sir
p'ing corvo's role as the protagonists
are as one of the protagonists forget
when the specifics are that's probably
the one I'm looking forward to most see
what they do with that what the arcane
does with that because Arcana such a
talented studio and they did such a
great job kind of bringing this new IP
out that was kind of weird we first saw
it and who's this person like
teleporting around was a tracer like you
said and now we are kind of on the cusp
of the sequel and I'm hoping they can
follow through with it I'm very much
looking forward to sort of what the
console manufacturers have to say about
I guess you know PlayStation with the
neo the 4.5 I want to see like you know
PlayStation VR if we've got any like
bundles and prices and stuff like that
and then it'll be interesting to see if
Microsoft's you know flinch in relation
to that as well do they get off their
arses and talk about doing the same
thing do they double down on us did I
make a whole new type of xbox perhaps
getting do they you know that's space
between consoles and PC that they keep
on closing do they sort of merge those
two things netted Windows 10 is kind of
gone across the board should not one of
the things that I would like to see
people talk about which is just quality
of life is the cross play idea hmm I
were a second I Tory some lacrosse play
and yeah I always your lacrosse a sweet
pair cause it's all that looking for the
crowd cheering permanently yeah a cross
play like yeah end of fiefdom get rid of
it like I want to play with whoever on
whatever and if I'm on my pc at night
and I want to play with my friend who's
on xbox one or ps4 I can't tell you how
many times I've been
isolated for my friends just because
like we had different consoles in
different systems or like your ability
to play the same game on multiple
platforms just that sort of freedom of
choice to be such a good quality of life
improvement for gamers yeah if they can
work it out that pushes and pulls in so
many directions because sometimes you
don't buy a game because you like all my
friends won't get it on that platform so
i won't i'll wait and get it here or
maybe i'll bite the other console but
then sometimes it actually helps them
because you're like all my friend has
that console so i better get that
console so that we're all you know
working in the same sort of ecosystem
happier right like that there is
definitely a push towards that I mean
rocket League you know is now across the
board so it also likely late in the life
cycle of games when player populations
dwindle there can be that effect where
they get too low and then it just tanks
because there isn't enough people to
play pineville you consolidate all those
people into one pool and suddenly you've
got multiplayer games that have much
greater longevity because you can
maintain that community for a longer
period of time yeah there we go I guess
we'll have more updates in the coming
weeks let us know you excited free 3 one
of the some of the enhancements you're
looking forward to more than anything
else stick them down there in the
commons